Mickey,
I don't know what to do.
I really need my viewers to think that
I'm amazing with languages.
I'm really not,
but I need them to think that,
well,
I don't need their validation,
but they're always asking me if I am a
super polyglot,
like all those people selling ebooks,
but how do I get rid of attachments,
but I might fail.
Hello language enthusiasts.
Today I'm going to play the great
language game.
This idea is totally original.
I didn't get this idea from Pewdiepie or
Jack's,
but I see.
No,
I had this idea of long before them in
this game I'll hear some samples of
languages and I will have to guess what
languages they are.
At the end of the game I'll get a score
that reflects my ability to guests the
languages.
This is kind of like the mystery
languages videos that I've made,
like these ones right here,
except that I'll be guessing the
languages instead of you,
so I'm ready to fail and embarrass
myself for your entertainment.
Let's go.
Alright,
here it is the great language game.
I'm clicking play right?
No,
anecdotally what I want you in and when
I go,
no meter.
She the sound quality.
Get any worse
Spanish?
Yes.
You got it.
Okay.
That wasn't too hard.
Okay,
cool.
Cool.
Choreograph production assistant.
So for just two boys,
the boys were either three,
but see Miss Tula.
Um,
this one's finished.
I really don't know the sounds of
finished that well,
but it wasn't there a big.
It wasn't Chinese,
it wasn't Vietnamese.
So by process of elimination,
I know it's finished.
You got it.
Okay.
And Do,
do you know kids?
You took me back.
They didn't tell him you got to.
Okay.
So this is Korean?
I don't speak Korean,
but I hear Korea,
Korean,
a fair bit.
Living here in Japan there are a lot of
Korean visitors,
so I know a few words and I know the
sounds of Korean.
That's this one.
Okay.
Just to you or sample boning a
state called the police and Eliade punt
on the ombuds business on my Monterrey
there or something.
It sounds like Norwegian,
like it's this one.
Nice.
Okay.
You're happy but as duty.
Who is the police?
Negotiate.
But I a bar.
Okay,
this one is not Vietnamese.
It's not Polish.
It's not Korean,
so it's either Hindi or my ruthy.
I'm,
I'm not sure which one,
but I'm just going to go with Hindi
because that's the only one I've really
heard.
I've heard Matthew A.
Little bit,
but not really.
And you got it.
Okay.
Yeah.
Need little school called for and Steve
some stains so we go through a Yada,
Yada.
Adam as some the data,
the less of a need.
Yeah,
sounds like Norwegian to me.
Nice.
Okay.
We heard that one before.
That gives you love those to,
to and foremost we give so much of it
but it's still a lot.
But will he will go strongly coupe.
What do you think of the blue?
What would you know post in the group?
Hmm.
Well the sound Slavic to me,
but it doesn't sound Russian.
I don't know specifically what the
difference is,
but I've never really encountered much
Polish so I'm going to say Polish
because it sounds Slavic,
but not rushing to me.
It could be wrong.
Let's see.
It was Russian.
What do you know
if at the moment this was the motiva?
Okay,
well that one's pretty easy because I'm
studying Italian,
so I hear it quite a lot.
Italian?
Yes.
Okay,
good.
Good for you.
Good.
We'll build the oil.
Thenthe.
Hooshball.
Saville Blair's social listening.
Okay,
so that one is Portuguese.
So I heard some romance vocabulary in
there that I recognized even though I've
never studied Portuguese.
You got it all right.
Yeah.
Come.
Yeah,
that kid looking shall be doable.
You have to.
Budgeting Bundy.
Ubi,
new Lulu flinging.
She.
I,
similarly for that bank and me combined
until.
Okay.
I think this is Vietnamese,
my hair,
some tones in there and I'd been to
Vietnam and I've heard the language
before.
I think that's the one.
All these others.
None of these other ones have tones as
far as I know.
Here we go.
Good
adult talking to your leader there,
but it still took a second to.
Makes students found that would get.
I keep getting shit that you can get you
off the cuff.
Fumbled Nigga to the lesson and
telephone that he'd been with the
village.
And let me hear this again.
Adult Adhd.
It will.
You smack is going to be as North Korea.
They stole them.
Um,
I don't know what this language here is
or septic,
but it doesn't sound like any of the
others to me.
So I'm going to choose that one.
MMM.
Turkish.
Sorry.
Okay.
Next
cleaning up.
His gift to you move distally means good
vote.
Your heart can swallow or know some
hills.
Oh yeah.
Mr Fadley,
team tango somewhere.
So distal to you.
Have you.
Have you helped over the,
of your portfolio at still the most?
Sydney?
Yes.
I don't understand what the hell they're
saying.
So I think it's Danish.
You got it.
Alright.
Okay.
Turn that down.
Sure.
How can they indicate some book?
I teach you how much he took.
Hey.
Give me more.
Come on.
Okay.
Did they indicate some book?
I teach you good bunker sammy.
But in the door Heidi,
I heard something about Boko Haram.
It doesn't sound like Chinese doesn't
sound like Norwegian or Polish or
Spanish or Ukrainian.
I don't know about Uzbek.
Uh,
but because of the content,
I think it's Hausa.
Nice.
Okay,
good.
Your bond k video on it.
There's no law.
You the team's leader more by emotional
particular mesh with the law here,
leaving made as I was starting to get
pretty close to Manila.
Nash rapists that some are religious
will show a monitor bunco routed for a
more beating their really believed
process throughout.
Okay.
Yes.
I believe there's no law.
You mean by emotional and particularly
the mashers law here.
Alyssa,
you made as I was starting to get pretty
close.
The sound's definitely slavic to me,
but I'm not sure if it's Russian or
Ukrainian.
Um,
let's see.
I'm going to pick Ukrainian kind of a
crap shoot.
You got it?
Yes.
All right.
Luck of the draw.
What do you will.
You are not my cause.
Yo.
Would you want more door?
No.
One to another.
See what a d.
f who you.
Because you hop up.
My mom did you know lucky
Bossy Cmi.
Moya at sweeter but accidentally.
Hmm.
Okay.
I think that once Swahili,
it doesn't sound like any of the others.
And something about the tone bursts.
Sounded Swahili to me.
Yes.
Oh,
right.
Got It.
Next
that I am as they do that.
Also a human that I watched Steve.
Lovely.
It was a big stone.
The COC mass shootings.
Who I'm getting tired.
I have to focus.
Okay.
Steve was big on the COC.
Mass shooting goes,
a capitation went out of their mouths.
Okay.
Um,
I think it's Uzbek mainly because it
doesn't sound like any of the others.
And some of the pronunciation sounded
like it had Russian influence and I know
that it was Becca.
Stan has been influenced by Russia.
So let's say it was bag.
Yes.
All right.
That was right.
I've only got one life left.
This is nerve rattling.
Newer Kumba be slamming state.
No secret was Sunni initially out of the
way there on Cassini might not even need
but the dod.
I think this is why he be again.
Yes.
Okay.
Some,
I heard some words that sounded like
they were borrowed from Arabic and
they've retained the Arabic
pronunciation and I know that's why he
really has some Arabic words.
So that helped me to guest
who's coming in to spend.
They need me.
Japan's could do my Baltimore.
Okay.
That was French.
I know some French,
yes.
Okay.
What's next?
It almost always eat breakfast.
Anything hit Hitler chosen this way or
have embedded of temperature in being
available today in the.
Cool.
I need to focus.
Every time I get one right.
That kind of relaxed and I think.
Oh,
okay.
Now I can stop focusing,
but I need to think about the next one.
Okay.
Wake up Paul.
Wake up.
Focus.
So Christina,
do you like these directly to them as
possible for me,
a place in another state when he's been
eating.
I think it's Danish again because I
don't understand what they're talking
about.
Correct.
Whenever I have no idea what any of the
words are.
It's Danish.
That's because of the porridge and their
mouth porridge in the throat.
She was from the court that she have
not.
Oh,
we plugged that in.
British new sophistication students
you said,
but I'm going to play that again because
I couldn't that
I get it up to the court that she was
not delta that British because now they
made it so far as you said.
Well that sounds Slavic against me.
Russian or this one.
Oh,
ascetic.
Which must be a slavic language.
Which one?
Eeny.
Meeny.
Miny.
Moe.
Catch a tiger by the toe.
Russians.
More common.
Go with that.
You got it.
Okay.
I gotta look into this language or
setting.
I don't know what it is.
I'll probably get a lot of comments
telling me what you don't know what it
is,
but I don't God to the sound quality.
Get any worse.
Come on.
Find some clear samples
or the.
For the year I've been fuzzy on me with
our and now we have a lot of my youth.
Do you think it's authentic this time?
You got it.
Okay.
Alright.
Let me play that again.
That's why he the again.
Mm.
No.
What was it?
Hindi.
Whoops.
Okay.
I heard some words that sounded like
Arabic to me,
so I thought they were Swahili words.
I guess Hindi has some words like that
too.
Well,
there it is.
My score is 950.
See,
my knowledge of languages is not
perfect.
Sometimes it's a guessing game and I'm
just looking for little pieces that I
can analyze and try to figure out what's
going on.
Even if I'm not sure,
I hope you enjoyed this video and I also
hope that you learned a thing or two,
why don't you try the great language
game and leave your score in the
comments down below.
Maybe you'll beat me.
Be sure to follow Lang,
focus on facebook,
twitter,
and Instagram,
and once again,
thank you to all of my patrion
supporters,
especially these magnificent people
right here on the screen for their
monthly pledges.
Thank you for watching and have a nice
day.